I'm Jennifer brainy and I am the host of
the Congressional just podcast filling
in for David today while he travels to
Vegas where he will be reporting for you
for the rest of the week but beginning
back to the story that I started in the
last segment in late March Congress very
quickly passed in president Trump signed
a 2232 page law that funded the
government six months late for 2018
because the bill was so long and rushed
through votes so quickly there were
provisions in it that many in Congress
didn't even know about and one of these
provisions was buried at the end of the
law and it was called the cloud act the
cloud act is essentially yet another
erosion of privacy rights of individuals
not just in the United States this time
but around the world
now the backstory on this law is that
the Supreme Court was considering
arguments in a case that questioned the
reach of US law enforcement into the
foreign operations of US tech companies
because five years ago Microsoft was
served with a warrant for emails as part
of a drug trafficking investigation
Microsoft handed over some information
like the metadata type information but
they refused to give the government the
content of the targets emails because
they were stored at a Microsoft data
center in Ireland where the target lived
when he opened his Microsoft email
account
Microsoft told the government that to
get the contents of the emails the
government should go to Irish officials
which shouldn't have been all that
difficult because the United States and
Ireland already have signed a mutual
legal assistance treaty which allows
them to work together for law
enforcement purposes but the Justice
Department wanted the emails handed to
them directly by Microsoft and so this
went to court but instead of letting the
courts decide someone in Congress
probably senator Orrin Hatch of Utah
because he wrote it but someone slipped
the cloud Act into the must sign omnibus
which essentially blew up the Supreme
Court case what the cloud Act does is
that it essentially says that warrants
like the one issued to Microsoft in the
United States would apply to date a
sword stored overseas but the new law
lets tech companies challenge the
warrants in court if they think that
complying would break the law of the
country where the data is stored and I
guess that's a good thing but the thing
is that the law went further than that
it also allows foreign governments to
get the contents of communications
stored in the United States now an order
issued by a foreign government will have
to identify a specific person account
address or personal device and the order
has to be for a fixed limited amount of
time and one good thing here is that
these orders by foreign governments are
subject to review by our courts but the
question then becomes what foreign
countries would be eligible for this
partnership because not all countries
are great countries when it comes to
civil liberties human rights like who
can we trust
well that's where this law gets more
troubling because it allows the US
Justice Department to enter into
executive agreements with other
countries to set up this information
sharing relationship before the cloud
Act if a foreign government wanted to
get this kind of electronic data from
tech companies for an investigation they
would have had to have signed one of
those mutual legal assistance treaties
with the US government which requires
ratification by the US Senate but the
cloud act which is now law allows the
Attorney General almost single-handedly
to sign executive agreements with other
countries that would allow foreign
governments to get data hosted in the
United States just as long as their
target is not American or living in the
United States all the Attorney General
would have to do is submit a
certification to Congress that the
country is basically cool with civil
liberties but the certifications written
by the Attorney General are prohibited
from being reviewed in our courts and so
basically if the Attorney General says
the other government is trustworthy
that's it case closed so it jeff
Sessions says the other government is
trustworthy
that's it tastes closed and the only
thing that Congress can do to stop this
this country is a good spying partner
determination by the Attorney General is
enacted joint resolution disapproving of
the determination which is a very
similar process to passing a bill and
that's a high hurdle in a Congress that
can't even fund the government properly
and so basically the cloud Act really
lowered the bar for intergovernmental
partnerships for sharing the contents of
digital data because these relationships
used to have
to be created with legit treaties
ratified by two-thirds of the Senate now
it's up to Jeff sessions or whoever
comes after him and that's a huge change
and then there's the way it was done
because the cloud act before hitchhiking
its way into law on the government
funding law well it was only introduced
in both the house in the Senate and the
significance of that is that there was
never a single hearing with experts in
this Congress this bill never passed
through a committee it was never debated
in or passed by itself through the house
and it was never debated in or passed by
itself through the Senate it went
immediately from zero to law and this is
why funding the government in these big
monster omnibus laws is so dangerous
because you never know when stuff like
this is gonna get slipped in today's
episode of the program is made possible
in part by Cody which is an innovative
new cryptocurrency and online payment
platform that wants to revolutionize how
we send and receive online payments cody
stands for currency of the internet and
the goal is to build an infrastructure
for online payments that simple
transparent trustworthy instantaneous as
well as scalable and today's payment
solutions have a number of different
trust and usability problems whether
it's between consumers or between
businesses or between consumers and
businesses and Cody wants to solve a lot
of those problems through their currency
and platform which unlike a lot of the
Kryptos and block chains that are out
there have actually been created
specifically and solely to be used for
payments cody has set out to do this by
using innovative base layer protocol in
the form of a directed acyclic graph
based ledger built from transactions
connected through time by harnessing
trust based algorithms if you're
watching this on youtube you can find
out more about cody and their initial
coin offering in the links below this
video this is not financial advice and
everybody should do their own research